cowboys uh they they may be hitting the
ground running for earl thomas now that
they've told haha clinton dicks to hit
the road
what what do you think ultimately
contributed to the former first round
pick of the green bay packers when
mike mccarthy was there as a head coach
for mccarthy to come to
dallas and say yeah we traded you away
when i was when i was in green bay now
we're telling you to
get out of here now that i'm in dallas
yeah you know he didn't win the starting
job he was beaten out by darien thompson
the former third round pick of the
giants
who didn't do anything there and it you
know it it's
a strange situation that haha clinton
dicks couldn't come in
and win the starting job but he didn't
do that and and so the cowboys
continually have this question at safety
as they do and that
do again this year and and they had a
chance last year
to to fix this situation in the draft
they had a chance when they drafted
tristan hill in 2019 in the second round
there were all those safeties sitting
there there taylor rapp was sitting
there
there were three of them one thorn hill
was sitting there and they had a chance
to draft one of those safeties who went
in the picks right after them
and they didn't do that they had a
chance in a trade quandary
quandary jigs if you look at what the
the seahawks gave up for him they had a
chance to make that trade
uh minka fitzpatrick if they didn't you
know if they wanted to give up the
bigger draft
compensation to get somebody like that
but they had all these chances to
improve their safety position and they
haven't done it and here they sit
mike do you know who their last pro bowl
safety was the cowboys last pro bowl
safety it was so long ago what
was it charlie waters jokingly but maybe
i'm right
yeah well you know who it was probably
darren williams and when we
well it was roy williams playing with
darren woodson but when we think of roy
williams who do we think of we think of
the receiver roy williams who played for
the cowboys not the safety roy williams
who played for the cowboys but it was
roy williams it was that long ago
and they just had this this question
mark at that position for so long and
they haven't addressed it
and i think it was why the tampa ii
defense under rod marinelli never lived
up to the expectations
that they had because you have to have
that safety in that defense you have to
have a john lynch
who's wrecking havoc back there not
making the interceptions but wrecking
havoc
or you have to have somebody like a
charles tillman
in the secondary with the bears which is
what he had who's forcing all those
turnovers that charles tillman forced
back in the day but they didn't have
that at corner or safety
uh when he was there and they moved by
if you remember they moved byron jones
all around
they they couldn't decide well is he a
safety is he a corner they started him
at safety and then they moved in a
corner finally said all right we got to
leave you
at quarterback when chris richard came
in
but they've just never gotten that
safety position right
since roy williams and and again they go
into a season with a huge question mark
at that position again
poor roy williams couldn't even keep his
name on the roy williams rule they
eventually just called it the horse
collar tackle rule and
they originally called it the roy
williams rule he was the reason why
the horse collar tackle became illegal
he broke terrell owen's leg back in 2004
knocked him out of the balance of the
regular season post season up until the
super bowl and he had that great
performance even though the leg was
still broken
but yeah i guess why are we calling it
the roy williams well why are we naming
it after a receiver so uh we just call
it the horse caller rule instead
earl thomas there are no there aren't
two earl thomases in the nfl there isn't
an earl thomas the receiver yet earl
thomas the safety isn't in the nfl
does the departure of haha clinton dicks
open the door for earl thomas or do the
cowboys continue to stay put
well i would say absolutely not and
everything i've gotten in response to
asking cowboys officials are you
interested are you interested
the answer comes back no we're not but
at the same time there's only one guy we
know in that organization that makes
decisions
and he has been known to make decisions
against what others
want in the organization and that's
jerry jones we've seen it repeatedly so
until jerry jones says
no we don't want earl thomas i don't
think you take them out of play for earl
thomas but i
think others in the organization do not
want
earl thomas but ultimately is jerry
jones going to be talked off this ledge
or is he going to
go out there and say we really need earl
thomas
and the fact that we're closing in on
two weeks since the ravens abruptly cut
earl thomas
continues to provide proof that thomas
isn't regarded by teams as one of the
higher end safeties in the nfl if he
were he would have been signed as
quickly as leonard fournette
was signed for net within 24 hours after
landing
on the free agency market had a new team
earl thomas
still waiting and i have a feeling he's
going to continue waiting and i agree
with you even though
jerry jones likes to keep the door open
because i think jerry jones just likes
to have
any reason whatsoever for people to be
talking about the cowboys i don't think
the cowboys are going to make that move
and i don't know who's going to make it
probably the patriots so probably
since they didn't get leonard fournette
they'll probably have earl thomas and
jadavian clowny
by the time week one rolls around
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports